you
[Music]
such an honor to have dine Kleinberg
visit us today for the distinguished
lecture at Emma sorry I John is the
Tisch University professor in the
department's of computer science and
information science at Cornell
University his research focuses as you
all know and very interesting issues at
the interface of algorithms networks and
information with an emphasis on the
social and information networks that
underpin the web and other media we just
had we just came out of a fireside chat
that'll be on hopefully edited and
available soon where John talked about
his early days and reflections and
interested in law and mathematics and
wondering if you'd ever combine these
things together in some issues that
might come to the fore some day while
staring at an Apple 2 computer and
writing simple programs and in fact that
he discovered a few years later that
this was actually a field whole computer
science that brought some of these ideas
to life but probably even back then had
no idea where things were going in terms
of the work that and the and the
challenges and opportunities we now face
as a community John's a member of
National Academy of Sciences National
Academy of Engineering and the recipient
of fellowships from MacArthur Packard
Symons and the sloan foundation and he's
won a number of prizes the Harve prize
the Nevin Nevin Lena Prize Newell award
and the ACM prize in computing knowing
or a bunch of actual work and following
it closely I'm sure all of those prizes
were well deserved so John come on
thanks Pete
all right it's a badge they're great
well thanks thanks very much for the
invitation to to come speak here and
it's been a really fun day getting to
meet with so many people whose work I
really admire and enjoy keeping up with
so I want to talk today about some work
I've been doing jointly with Sendhil
mullainathan behavioral economist at
Harvard who have known for a long time
and two of my PhD students Mini's
Rogovin and my throw ragout thinking
about issues in in sort of this this
emerging space of topics that sort of
goes under the name algorithmic fairness
and the talk will really be about some
definitional questions and really a lot
of the focus will actually in this work
be maybe about some of the aspects where
we take different competing demands for
what it would mean for a decision rule
to be fair and try to evaluate how these
decisions and these definitions they
interact with each other and I'll try to
sort of highlight some things that I
think we learned that's that surprised
us once we sort of started to sort out
out some of these definitions conceptual
issues so this actually started from
some work that sandal and I were doing
on human decision-making and really
looking at the intersection of
algorithmic and human decision-making we
were motivated by the fact that in
computer science
and in the social sciences there are
activities that superficially look very
different that syntactically have a
surprising amount in common with each
other so if I think about computer
science a canonical sort of decision
that we've gotten very good at is the
sort of decision that you see embodied
in a ranking function or a
recommendation function right this is a
screenshot from a tutorial blog post on
Netflix showing how it's making
recommendations and essentially from a
you know huge amount of data about a
user as all of you know it abstracts
some kind of a sparse set of features
that's somehow a thin representation of
this you know rich living breathing
individual and it tries to predict are
they going to like this movie right it's
going to assign a probability estimate
to that based on data they have about
them and data they have about many other
people
and these kinds of activities in the
online world are things that you know
we've developed a lot of practice at
refining and improving but meanwhile in
the offline world as sundel observed to
me there are activities that human
beings are doing that look somewhat
similar right so hiring for example
which superficially very different
certainly each individual decision
there's more high stakes but we take an
individual job applicant who's a complex
living breathing human being they submit
something like a resume a CV maybe a
school transcript and some hiring
committee looks at this and decides will
this person be a good employee in fact
part of the decision is to make a
prediction will they do well in the
environment at our company same thing
happens with college admissions you take
a college applicant you get some set of
features about them and some committee
of making decision which is in part
based on a prediction an estimate of
their probability of succeeding in this
program now in the offline world these
are relatively high stakes just
decisions compared with ranking a
recommendation where maybe billions of
low stakes decisions are being made by
the algorithm but fundamentally they all
sort of follow this this common pipeline
right we're mapping individual features
to an algorithm and some sort of
predictions being made here all think of
the prediction as maybe a probability
estimate I'm gonna sign a probability
are you you know about some future
behavior are you gonna be in in the
positive class or the negative class so
you're going to be a yes or a No right
are you going to like the movie you're
gonna succeed as an employee so forth
there once we think about this pipeline
and how it lives both in the online in
the offline world there are a lot of
questions that people have have have
begun to ask including questions over
here on the right hand side is the right
outcome actually being predicted right
when I try introducing an algorithm into
some complex situation and say I'm here
to make a prediction are you really
making a prediction that's relevant to
the overall decision that society's
trying to optimize
similarly lots of questions get asked
about this mapping are we recording the
right features about an individual are
those features reflecting problems that
we have even in the
in the in the construction phase and
finally related to these first two
points this broad question of is the
algorithm making fair decisions right
are the elements decisions fair and
there's clearly a complex definitional
question there so what we mean by
fairness and so that's what I want to
start from in this talk the question of
what would it mean for what me for an
algorithms decisions to be fair and here
are a slightly more specific question
what it mean for an algorithmic
prediction to be fair I mean
particularly interested here in in this
act of prediction and assigning an
estimate of a probability now I've shown
you some examples online content
employment education all of these have
this kind of thing we could run through
many other settings where some sort of
hybrid of a computer in a human decision
maker are making predictions right in
granting loans and making medical
diagnoses wide range of areas where this
template actually fits quite well I want
to talk about the domain that sandal I
have been focusing on for the past
several years which is criminal justice
and we have been working together with
yonce Ludwig Eurail s Kovac and he
melaka raju on developing prediction
algorithms in this domain and trying to
look for places where human judges might
be might be making errors may be making
suboptimal decisions and around the time
we were doing that this extremely widely
circulated article by ProPublica came
out in summer 2016 gathered a huge
amount of attention and it was focused
on a risk tool that was actually being
used in parts of the US criminal justice
system this tool called compass and so
what was compass doing compass at a very
high level was taking features about
individual defendants and trying to
assign a level of risk a risk that they
would reoffending our powers of
measurement at least the risk that they
would be really okay and so it was doing
this sort of a prediction activity and
there were some it appeared problems
with compass and so ProPublica did this
investigation and it was actually a very
nice example of two Teta journalism
where
the data they used to evaluate compass
the code they used evaluation they put
all that on github so that people could
replicate what what they were doing and
they arrived at some relatively striking
findings which they reported in thirty
six point font in their article they
identified some form of bias in the
decisions it was making now what was the
bias that they identified here it is
sort of summarized in two bullet points
in stylized form i n for those of you
who can't quite read the bottom of slide
i'll i'll read it out for you so this is
assigning a level of risk to each
defendant but each defendant then goes
out in the world in either commits
either reoffended which again really to
with our powers and measure means gets
redirected or not and so the first
finding was that african american defend
defendants who didn't subsequently riaf
end had higher average scores than white
defendants who didn't subsequently be
offend and this first bullet point was
concerning because what we're talking
about this first bullet is a whole bunch
of people none of whom did anything
wrong in the future and yet the average
score assigned to the african-american
defendants in that category was higher
than what was signed to the white
defendants conversely the same thing
happened in the opposite direction with
people who did riaf end
white defendants who subsequently
reoffended had lower average scores than
african american defendants who said
something given okay so both of these
seem like some source of concern and
especially the first bullet is a good
one to focus on right people who didn't
do anything wrong in the future and yet
we're getting these different scores and
you think of the scores signed to
somebody as it incurs a big cost on
their right if you get a high score
that's now something which is which
which has consequences it in how you get
treated by by the US criminal justice
system okay yeah yeah yeah so right so
this is something that we dealt with a
lot in in the work that we've been doing
where if i release someone i find out
what happened if I don't really someone
in these particular cases these refer
offenses that we're gonna involve
relatively short term detention and so
they were using what happened after they
were released either immediately or
eventually I
too many issues one of which is is that
one make this kind of analysis much more
complicated and in the kind of activity
that followed this report a lot of the
methodology here was question was
refined and so forth fundamentally this
category of objections was robust in the
sense that for a lot of different ways
of looking at this this seemed to be
happening yeah other questions about the
yes you're assuming so the average you
saying to every score yes is higher but
as I said to school yeah there was a so
I mean the question will be to get into
like why is this happening I agree
we should be having but you know we
should remember that in the end if we
think about this as an activity in the
world right so when we say they have to
do with the features we have to do with
covariance and the features and so forth
that's fine but that was our decision to
impose that structure in the situation
what's actually happening in the world
is defendants walk into a courtroom
they're assigned scores where high
scores impose a relatively high cost on
them in and how they retreat in the
future scores get assigned to them they
leave the courtroom and none of them do
anything wrong right so in the world
that's happening as people pass through
the system don't really run in the
future yet we've picked this category of
people and we've assigned them higher
scores we could discuss why we're doing
that but fundamentally that end-to-end
process seems like it has something
wrong with it and now that was
fundamentally their argument okay so in
the analysis that that followed the
first thing happened was people said all
right well if this is an issue with the
compass risk tool maybe something if we
want to understand what's happening can
we understand at least what compass was
optimized to do and there actually was
an interesting point here and this was
made both by people who were involved
with the creation of the compass tool
and also by a collection of researchers
in crime policy who pointed out that
there's another definition that we
should be thinking about when we
evaluate risk tools which was not the
ones that ProPublica suggested but
rather this notion of calibration and
fact compasses scores were a real well
calibrated for each group separately so
what do I mean by calibration so we
could think of a risk tool as you know
just discretizing the space of risks and
so it's assigning defendants to these
bins this is the point one wrist pin
point two points over point one means
you have a 10% chance of reoffending and
again whenever I say reoffending I mean
reoffending in the context where you've
been arrested by the criminal justice
system which is all that were measuring
and so if it's well calibrated be the
case that when I look into the spin one
tenth of all the people there did riaf
end because one tenth should mean one
tenth and when I look into the point
tube in a point two fraction the people
should reoffending two means and indeed
that is the property that the compass
scores had and it had it separately for
each group it had it for the African
defendants and half for the white
defendants right so their point was when
we assigned an african-american
defendant a score of 0.2 it means point
two if you were to go and look later
twenty percent of those people
reoffended point to men point two if you
look at the white defense you got
assigned to score point two point two
men point two right so there's in their
argument you know there's not much more
we can do beyond that promise we promise
that the numbers would mean what they
said they do mean what they said and
adding you know adding race into this
does not differentiate between that
because it's calibrated and separately
within each group the score have asked
me is the same thing now you could ask
well its calibration import I mean it
sounds good
do we is there some societal benefit to
having calibration for one thing it
feels somehow like important that your
tools output means what it claims to
mean but it's also the case that
uncalibrated rules can induce bad
behavior so let me just tell a sort of
fictitious pedagogical story about a
world in which some entity uses an
uncalibrated tool and let's think about
what might happen right so suppose in my
fictitious world hospitals run a tool to
predict very accurately how good a
doctor you're going to be and they hire
candidates by strapping them into bins
and only hiring the camps with the very
highest score s star okay but suppose
the rule is not calibrated across groups
right in particular that would mean
something like female doctors with the
score esto are actually more likely to
be good doctors than male doctors with
the same score estar
right estar does not mean estar for the
two groups in fact the probability is
higher for the female doctor to get
scores too right that would be what it
would mean for the rule beyond
calibrated then the point is as a
patient it would now actually become
rational for you to choose your doctor
at least in part based on their gender
gender has now actually become an
informative feature in your selection of
doctors the tool actually is encouraging
you do that it says in fact when one
group actually has a higher probability
being a good doctor than than the other
so even if you're sort of imposed
self-discipline and choose to ignore
this fail of calibration the downstream
people in society may not be doing that
so this is one of the styles of
arguments why you might want calibration
across groups okay so calibration is
important on the other hand
ProPublica objections still remained
right they still seem to this problem so
the question was could we achieve all of
these desired properties at once we now
have multiple properties all of which
seem to connote fairness and at this
point in elaborate argument ensued and
sindelle and Manish and I sort of
watching this felt like if we get at
least write down the definitions that
people are arguing about which is so far
gone sort of only partially specified
maybe we could actually look at the
situation and try to figure out what the
argument is actually about and so this
next next few slides is really about
something which mathematically ends up
not being that hard the challenge is to
figure out what is the sort of
definitional content of this argument so
here's what we're talking about in terms
of the model so the basic model for
assigning risk scores as probability
estimates is that I have individuals
they each have two things that are
salient they're either positive or
negative right they will reoffended they
won't be offended employer they won't be
a good employee there's some kind of
notion of the positive class than the
negative class and they also belong to
one of two groups right two groups where
I'm interested in the imbalance between
them or lack thereof groups ARB the you
know gets me up to a feature vector and
then my risk score maps them to one of a
set of bins bin B has a score visa B
which is sort of the probability
estimates
okay so and that's fundamentally what
whatever stool is doing what are the
properties that I would like for my from
my wrist tool well here are the three
that we've been talking about so far
calibration within groups means that for
each group a and B a V sub B fraction
people in bin B or in fact positive then
I have these issues that ProPublica
raised right these definitions which
really hadn't necessarily been as much
on the radar in the in the discussion
about these things and until the report
came out so on the positive class we
might ask for what I might call balance
that the average score of the positive
members in Group A should equal the
average score of the positive members in
Group B and similarly I might want
balance for the negative class that the
average score of negative members in
Group A should equal the average score
of negative members in Group D three
properties that I'm at I am I might
watch all of which seems to connote some
kind of fairness in the system okay
so let's ask how might we try to achieve
all of these properties well let's first
try out some simple cases where we could
achieve them the first case would be if
I can have if I have perfect prediction
which is a really extreme case then I
can actually achieve all three
properties right if the features in my
data are actually enough that I can
deterministically tell if someone's in
the positive class or the negative class
then when I'm deterministically sure as
someone's in positive class I give them
a score of one when I'm determined to be
sure they're in the negev class I give
them a score of zero and in fact all
achieve all three properties you can you
can check that yeah so how do you get
balanced so the average score of
positive member is and the average score
of in algorithm equal one in that case
as in if all members I saw the best case
is that you're positive exactly given
their positive yeah yep yeah so in the
case of perfect prediction which we
don't expect to have we could achieve
this um a second case may be a more
plausible case where we could also
achieve this would be equal base rates
suppose the two groups have the same
fraction of positive instances some
number P well then at least there always
is a risk
or that satisfies all three properties I
simply assign a probability P to
everybody I create one bin I put
everybody into it and they get a score
of P now clearly that satisfies balance
because everybody's average is P and it
also satisfies calibration because
there's a single bin and a P fraction
people in there
even so in that case I could at least
get your viler school maybe in the case
of equal base rates if there's some
structure in the problem I could create
another solution that's a more
non-trivial risk score with multiple
bins but the very least I can satisfy
all three properties okay so we now have
sort of two endpoints here and so we
thought about okay how can we sort of
work our way in from these two extremes
and the sort of first main thing I want
to talk about is that you can't actually
so in any instance of risk or assignment
when our all three properties can be
achieved you have to either have perfect
prediction or equal base rates these are
the only two situations in which you can
actually have all three of those
properties so I want to walk through why
that's true because as I said the proofs
in this section the talk are actually
quite easy and in some sense our
challenge had been to sort of unravel
what was being talked about and try to
fill out what the definitions were the
people were or arguing once you do that
it's it's not not that hard to see
what's going on and in particular I
should mention a couple of things about
this right the way we've defined things
it gets us to a point where this is not
a theorem that's about computational
power or inferential power it's really
just about your inability to assign
numbers to entities to equalize certain
averages right so as a result it's not
really about the limitations of
algorithms any decision-making procedure
that attempts to assign numbers to
people is going to fail on one of these
properties yeah cool no actually yeah
there we go place rates it's going to
depend on the instance so in fact a
slide that I don't have here if I give
you an instance of this problem with
equal base rates and I ask does there
exist a non-trivial score that's
actually np-hard to figure out if there
is or isn't because there's sort of a
knapsack like activity that you or
subset sum like activity you would have
to do and get a non-trivial one so yeah
so it's not it's gonna be instance
dependent
if you have perfect prediction for one
positive who are negative in both groups
when you sacrifice course on those
people to balance it out like suppose we
know that somebody's positive we can
assign any positive score debacle
somebody is negative any negative score
low threshold I see sorry are you
proposing a change in the requirement so
you're proposing a method if you know
one yes if I have equal base rates
that's how I could start to try finding
a non-trivial assignment of risk scores
I could sort of locally search for it in
that necessary if I have one equal base
raids as I'm gonna argue we're not
actually I'll do it yeah okay so this
was interesting to us because it it's it
it's something I've said that the crux
of this debate was that you really can't
achieve everything you have that people
want to unless you're on these
situations and fundamentally I'm saying
once you get one equal base rates
there's a problem right there's a
problem that these two groups have
unequal base rates and sort of no amount
of clever authoring of definitions it's
going to really make that go away it's
it's it's going to show up somewhere so
we went back talk to Pro Publica heavier
later because it generated a lot of
activity and a number of groups actually
were thinking about
similar sorts of questions and so these
all got summarized in a kind of year-end
wrap-up that they wrote coming back to
this question and saying that in fact
the situation was sort of it wasn't just
about the data that they had collected
there was there were certain
mathematical issues going on um some of
the other work that God summarized in
all of this there was some nice work
concurrent with ours by Alex jewelry
Cova at carnegie mellon looking at a
similar setting except where the
algorithm supposed to output a hard
decision not a probably estimate but a
yes/no decision and now I asked about
false positive rates and false negative
rates and there's a similar negative
result about equalizing certain sets of
false positive and false negative rates
similar results by a group at Stanford
corporate Davies at all some nice work
of Morris hards Eric price and knotty
shrub row who looked at the case in
which you take away calibration which
again comes with some costs
but then we could look at a constrained
optimization problem how can I be as
accurate as possible if I want to
equalize false positive rates equal
false negative rates or or in in our
terms impose balance for the positive
negative classes and then try be as as
accurate as possible which will
necessarily typically sacrifice
calibration we also in a paper at nips
this past year looked at some other
versions of this where for example if I
want to retain calibration I can
basically equalize any kind of
one-dimensional combination of the
balance for the positive classes but not
both both simultaneously
let me give you a quick sketch yes it
retsu question so can we get some
approximate version so if I write down
the notion of approximation in a really
sort of simple way I say I would like
approximate calibrations with an epsilon
I'd like equalizing averages with an
epsilon and I'd like equalizing balance
coast- with an epsilon then no in fact
basically it says you have to have
either approximately perfect prediction
or approximately equal base rates and
that's the only situation other forms of
approximation I think are sort of in
these lower bullets here where it's
basically saying we may have to just
wholesale give up on one of these
conditions and I and I think part of the
message here is going to be that which
condition you want to give up I'm gonna
argue as a sort of non technical point
is going to be domain dependence right
and there are certain extremes right
there are situations where you know the
societal cost of having unequal averages
for people who committed no crime for
example we view as very high and that's
one we want to focus on and if we lose
some calibration so be it
there are other domains we're giving up
on calibration for the sake of balance
you know seems to make very little sense
so for example take medical to take a
sort of a hypothetical medical diagnosis
setting where I have a rare disease
there's some tests for it which returns
with some probability and the disease
for some you know genuine genetic or
physical reason say is more common in
men than women okay so the base rates
are unequal so now the risk
for that disease fits in our framework
you take the features of the person you
output it probably that they have the
disease based on what you measured it
could be high it could be low based on
you know various tests that you ran but
because the base rates are unequal and
you have imperfect prediction and you're
gonna have some disparity across men and
women right there it feels like the fact
that the average for the positive class
and negative class are unequal is
somehow a feature of just the nature of
the disease right it's not necessarily
reflecting something wrong in society
relative just a fact about this disease
whereas having a rule that's on Calabria
in that case would be strange it would
mean you would go to the doctor and the
doctor would say well we looked at some
features and the thing reports you know
a 20% chance but because you're male we
have to adjust that because it's an
uncalibrated rule it's somehow wouldn't
necessarily sense to go calibration I
guess so I I think which one you want to
give up is going to be domain dependent
and it's going to pend on what we view
is the relative cost of these different
forms of unfairness
let me just mention a two slides about
the proof just to kind of emphasize that
it's really not not very complicated at
all once we have these definitions if
you if you if you want to watch for
something in in in in the proof it might
be the following which is somewhere in
the proof of course we're gonna have to
mention perfect prediction equal base
rates because the theorem is not you can
never do this the theorem is you can
only do in these two cases and these two
cases are kind of a combination of like
a zero dimensional case where things are
pinned down to constants and kind of a
one dimensional case where two things
are equalized so somewhere in the proof
short though it is is going to have to
be kind of a zero dimensional thing
glued to a one dimensional thing that's
going to somehow say these are the two
cases so watch for that okay so we have
these groups let's say M sub T is there
were people in group T K sub T is the
expect number of people in the positive
class and group team and I'm sort of
speaking informally in all this it takes
a little more to write this down more
carefully so the calibration condition
if you think about it says in this bin
one a have 10 people commit a crime and
we have 10 people assigned a score of
0.1 which is a total score of 1
similarly here we've assigned 10 copies
of 0.2 which is a total score of two and
two people commit a crime fundamentally
calibration is saying the total score
handed out in the bin is equal to the
expected people in that band who
actually are the positive class and
summing over all bins it basically says
the total score handed out to all of
t is going to be the expected number of
positive people all right
so let's remember that okay let's say we
have the average score per person the
negative class we'll call that X the
average score person the positive class
we'll call that Y the key is because
we've equalized the averages that's
independent the group we're talking
about that's crucial
so here's a way to write the total score
in group T NT minus K T people were in
the negative class they get score of X
on average Katie are in the positive
class they get score of Y on average on
the other hand we know that the total
score handed out is KT by calibration so
I get this equation so now I have two
equations one for the first group one
for the second group each of these
equations specifies some line relating
X&Y here are those two lines and now the
question is when can those be
simultaneously satisfied well one is at
the point zero one which is perfect
prediction and the other is if these two
slopes happen to be equal in which case
they coincide all the way along these
lines which is the case of equal base
roots and so fundamentally that's that's
what's going on and we have to be a
little more careful in how we write
everything down but that's that's
basically okay so we looked at this and
we thought they sort of dimension things
going on here and we began thinking
about the ways in which probability
estimates are being used more broadly
right so we we thought about this is
sort of one first look at this activity
of taking people and making
probabilistic estimates about them and
then making decisions based on that but
many of those situations involve more
than just one individual right what one
thing that's interesting here is that
we're auditing the rule we're evaluating
by looking at averages over groups but
the rule itself is being applied one
individual at a time fundamentally the
activity is the risk score takes in a
single individual and outputs a single
number and there are many cases when we
assign probablistic estimates about
people where we're really doing is
evaluating a group right we're applying
a function to a set not to an individual
what do I mean by that well we all sort
of encountered that on regular basis
right so just to take a sort of
represent example a couple years ago
there was this headline during college
admissions season in the Cornell
Chronicle which is our local on can
this news which says the amid class of
2019 is the most diverse in Cornell
history that's a statement about a group
same about the immediate class right no
one individual is the most diverse in
Cornell history it's really what happens
when you bring together a group of
people and evaluate the diversity as a
set I'm evaluating sense and this was
really a point brought to the fore by
the work of Scott page this social
scientists University of Michigan who
does very very stting work and has
written for a number of years on the
issue of diversity as a sort of emergent
property of groups and the performance
benefits of diversity and College
Admissions is one of the examples which
he which he thinks about but of course
there are a number of other settings
where we think with this like often
missing in the discussion of assignment
of soar loans for example or everything
people making loan decisions is that in
the end you have to evaluate loans
collectively right you're really
evaluating the portfolio of loans not
any one individually similarly a bunch
of work starting with work of Scott page
and then some subsequent work that my
throg you and I did which I'll mention
toward the end looking at for example if
I wanted to select a team to maximize
team performance
I should be evaluating the team not
necessarily the individuals on the team
okay so you end up with this challenge
in which we're trying to evaluate a
group by making probablistic estimates
about the individuals and what's going
to happen there so many strong men and I
having thought about this assignment of
risk scores began thinking about this in
the context of group selection and asked
what are some of the issues that come up
there and we came across this this
interesting thing which really hadn't
been sort of analyzed mathematically
which had some some interesting
properties so again to kind of recap
what we kind of a generic situation that
we're thinking about we have a large
pool of applicants we'd like to choose a
shortlist of K so maybe that's our
entering college class maybe I guess the
canonical example might be these are the
job applicants and we're gonna select K
to kind of interview or sort of look
extra hard at working and we'd like this
group of K to be as good as possible now
the concern is that there's bias in the
system either explicitly or maybe
implicit bias such that maybe group X
is a group where we're concerned there's
bias against critics so we have X
candidates and Y candidates depending on
their group membership and we're worried
that whoever's making the decision has
this bias against members of group X
where they sort of down weights down
weight them and either it's implicit
bias that they can't control or they
somehow choose not to control what do we
do in those kinds of situations so
there's an intervention that's become
increasingly popular in in the business
world in academia something called the
Rooney rule and actually a number of you
have no doubt encountered it even if you
haven't called it the Rooney rule and
that's saying when you're hiring for a
job for say a faculty position an
executive position what have you you
commit that on your short list of
interviewees you promise that at least
one of the people on that list will be
from griffix
okay hi this is the group you're
concerned that you're discriminating
against so if you see a pool of
interviewees and all of them are from
group Y then whoever is higher up in
management says I reject that list you
need to interview at least one person
group in X why is this called the Rooney
rule because the first really public
pronouncement and sort of commitment so
this actually came in 2002 by a by the
the owners of the teams in the National
Football League the Rooney rules named
after Dan Rooney who at the time was the
owner of the Pittsburgh Steelers we're
looking at the incredibly low
representation of minority head coaches
in the NFL which was of course
especially striking given the high
representation among the players for
example they want to figure out how
could we increase the fraction of head
coaches the NFL who are from minority
groups and so this was the rule that
they set out and it's become an
increasingly popular rule because it
somehow aims at the sort of middle layer
between you know no intervention just
everyone should try harder which felt
like it somehow wasn't getting anywhere
and more heavyweight interventions where
for example you commit to actually
hiring a certain number which then is
subject to sort of you know significant
or complex territory in discrimination
law right so this is somehow something
in in the in the middle you're
committing to look extra hard
and members of this group and so this
has become again sort of an increasingly
popular intervention it was invoked by
Barack Obama in 2015 where he exhorted
the tech industry to use this an
executive hiring when a commission
chaired by Eric Holder reviewed the
situation
uber in 2017 they made this among their
recommendations for executive hiring as
well okay that's the routing rule
it had an effect actually just to kind
of show a little day here this
interesting paper by Cynthia dupois from
two years ago looked at the moment the
rule was introduced just after the 2002
season what happened to the
representation of minority groups among
NFL head coaches and comparing it to a
bunch of reference populations where the
rule was not applied offensive and
defensive coordinators head coaches of
NCAA college teams none of whom were
actually using the Rooney rule and the
two had been sort of again there's a lot
of noise right this is incredibly small
numbers but the team have been sort of
roughly on top of each other and
diverged sharply right when the thing
wasn't you so there's evidence that this
was actually having an effect over time
but we actually want to ask in the
spirit of this work of Scott page you
want something about the performance
benefits of diversity right independent
of any of the other reasons that we
might do it couldn't simply be a
performance gain from imposing the
Rooney rule okay yeah know that this
rule is being applied when it is being
applied in the case of the NFL yes it's
situation dependent so the original
articulation of it was yes there was an
extremely public commitment to citizen
so everyone it was being played you can
imagine situations where and when a firm
decides to use it but not announce it
and then you might have a different
situation is there anything that happen
now that's the drop
there's been some discussion that
there's sort of two theories about this
one is it's small numbers this is noise
the other could be there's concern that
the rule is beginning to break down in
the increasingly people have a sense of
who they want as their head coach and so
you end up going committing to somehow
you know a set of interviews that don't
actually have much power because you've
sort of all already decided and so
there's concern that people are now have
learned how to engage in the rule sort
of in in in form but not in in in spirit
it's unclear though yeah okay so pure
performance benefits from this why might
there be a pure performance benefit from
using the Rooney rule in this case with
probabilistic prediction and again for
performance I need some kind of an
objective function and I'm gonna start
with the objective function that just
says I would like to maximize the sum of
the qualities of the K people that I
ain't ine interview there's a choice
there because you could say well I'm
just trying to hire one person I should
just maximize that person but there's
lots of evidence I'm one of the real
motivations behind introducing rules
like this is that all K people you
interview benefit from the exposure of
being interviewed for example the people
involved in interviewing them all go off
to go work for different firms or
different teams or whatever over time
and they're gonna be involved in
recruiting and they're gonna have people
who come to mind who are in their
working memory and if you were
interviewed earlier there's a benefit to
you so I'll start with something where
we're looking at the some of the
qualities of all K people you interview
in that all of them are somehow relevant
to the situation here's a model where
I'm gonna try to suggest that there
might be a performance benefit in cases
where there's biased evaluation okay the
models gonna have the following three
ingredients first I have a pool of job
applicants each one has some potential
for future performance this would be a
stylized model as with our previous set
of slides where I'm gonna try to what
are sort of the minimal set of
ingredients I'm gonna need to be able to
ask this question okay I'm gonna need
some kind of distribution over future
performance right hiring involves
someone certainty about like who is it
who's actually you know who I'm gonna be
getting most of the domains where the
Rooney rules being applied are what you
might call creative professions where
there's a kind of unbounded domain of
how good they could do in the future
again think about hiring researchers and
you know to take some craft numerical
measure may we're trying to estimate you
know at the end of their career what
will be their Google Scholar citation
count right a terrible thing to focus on
is a unit eventual quantity but sort of
it it conveys the idea right
you know if we're using this rule to
figure out you know who in our portfolio
of recording artists we hired we might
be looking at song downloads I'm looking
at revenue generated if we're trying to
hire salespeople and so forth all of
these have the property that they tend
to come from heavy tailed distributions
right there's an enormous amount of
empirical work now on citation
statistics let's say your lifetime
future citations is this heavy tailed
distribution in which outliers are quite
common so we'll imagine that your
probability that your lifetime output
exceeds T is some T of the minus 1 plus
Delta ok I think I actually have
parenthesized that wrong there should be
a minus s outside the parentheses ok so
good so this is a domain in which you
know this notion that we're trying to
hire superstars it's somehow formalized
by the fact that we have this very heavy
tail this region you see really big
numbers that's important ok second we
have candidates applying from groups x
and y and there there are different
compositions right if I have n canons
from group Y the groups the experience
is no bias I'll imagine I have alpha x
in from group X ok so because the second
thing that you have to worry about when
you think about applying there any rule
is how prevalent is this group in the
applicant population if they're only 1%
of the applicant population you pay a
very large cost by committing one of
your slots to them if they're at parity
if alpha equals one then in fact the
bias might be hurting a huge number of
people
ok I'm gonna make the assumption because
it's sort of the most basic assumption
can make that all are drawn from the
same power law distribution Z we clearly
look at the case where the two groups
maybe because of future bias they're
gonna experience might come my
experience different distributions going
forward in the future but we'll start
with this one and finally so far there's
no bias in this situation so far groups
x and y are indistinguishable let's say
add bias so there's some evidence from
psychometric work on implicit bias that
for some of these estimates when you
actually do experiments have people look
at Seavey's make estimates relative to
for example true lifetime citation
counts
there's often a something looks like a
multiplicative offset in these estimates
so we'll imagine there's a bias
parameter beta beta for bias greater
than one so that the selection committee
picking people believes that the
potential of the i-x candidate which is
X I they evaluated as X I divided by
beta so their estimate is knocked down
by data that may again because of
implicit bias they can't control me
because of explicitly us that they
actually are down waiting in but one way
or another that's what's happening and
then they have to pick a shortlist of K
so fundamentally it's this pipeline
applicants are drawn from this some are
X candidates some are Y candidates they
all get sorted but the X canidates all
gets scaled down by this factor 1 over
beta before they get merged sorted in
and then we picked the top K so for
example here if K were 3 the Rooney rule
wouldn't be necessary because one of
your three on your shortlist already is
an X candidate but if K were to this
list would be unacceptable you would
need to pick this third candidate and so
here's the question that we asked why
might the Rooney rule will be helping
after all I'm restricting your actions
previously you had an unconstrained
optimization problem or you could pick
any K you wanted now I'm making you only
pick lists of K where one of them is
from group X why might that possibly be
helping well because of course the point
is that the people group X have been
shifted down and so when I'm only
allowed to pick the top two and I swap
in this person for that person it might
be a win because this person may have
been better and was just divided that my
beta or maybe a loss because maybe the
reason this blue bar is above the red
ones because they really were better
right that's somehow the issue right
that what it's doing is putting people
into the shortlist who may have been
knocked out because of bias but may have
been knocked out just cuz they were
ranked lower that's what we have to
think about right so there may be a
performance gain there may be a
performance hit and we we have to figure
which one okay so that's the question
we're asking I should mention that
actually this is sort of natural example
of something from economic theory known
as delegation delegation is a which
actually dates back to one of the first
articulations of the theory delegations
actually in the Nobel laureate banked
Holstrom PhD
from the 1970s delegation is a very
constrained form of the broader topic of
mechanism design and mechanism design a
principle makes up a set of rules for a
game that agents play and they're trying
to create a certain behavior but mecha
design tends to involve things like
monetary transfers where you reward
people differently for what they do
delegation says we have a situation
where all the principal can do is refuse
to accept certain solutions they send
the agent out to search for a solution
but they say I'll reject the following
solutions with the following predicate
and so you have to find something that
passes my filter and by constraining the
agents action they're actually trying to
actually create a better solution by
overcoming budgets so there's a so you
think of the Rooney rule has a very
simple form of delegation where
somewhere higher up the chain someone
says I won't accept lists that are only
why candidates and finally the utility
is the case I was just okay so the main
result in in the work that Manisha I've
been doing is a characterization for
every shortlist size K of the choices of
alpha the pool composition what fraction
are x candace beta the level of bias and
Delta the power law exponent a bunch of
outliers for which the Rooney rule
producers actually a positive change in
expectation rather than a negative
change in expectation and yeah yeah yes
I said earlier where the other natural
thing would be the utility is some other
max I'll come back to max time
permitting I mean without time with that
um my argument for the sum is that in
many of these situations where the
Rooney rule is being applied it's in
some sense everyone is benefitting from
being interviewed again because of this
notion that in interviews are jeremy
more interviews both now and temporally
going forward ever may not be bad thing
equally the one that you choose is but
some appears sort of was actually part
of the original motivation right part of
your generation for interviewing
minority head coaching candidates was
that that was actually leading to sort
of them getting more interviews in the
future than being sort of more in the in
the sort of working set of people trying
trying to recruit so some is some kind
of approximation but I'll come back and
anything about max Alston it's also case
that the Rooney rule is increasingly
being
used for example for things like I'm
giving out a prize to five people I want
one to be from a group where I'm
treating them symmetrically you know I'm
creating an advisory committee of eight
people I want one to be and so they're
the use of some of this maybe even
working yeah right you might want
something where like yeah and that the
Dobby natural to look Allison okay so
you can get some characterization I want
to talk about a couple of things we sort
that we learn from thing about this
characterization and in particular I
wanted to independent Ekman details here
so does zero in on two things purely
mathematically about the nature of bias
that I feel like I didn't understand
before we did this that I now understand
better and so I want to sort of pull
those two out and talk about them okay
so first all here's the actual form the
statement for every constant K rhythm -
there's some explicit function v sub K
so it improves utility if and only if
some property of this is great in the
one implicitly this basically says if I
fix let's think about fixing alpha and
Delta what you're two things are
actually measurable or I can measure the
fraction of people who are X candids and
I can from past history measure the
distribution of lifetime future
performance and get some power law
exponent Delta alpha delts I know
beta is arguably the elusive one so you
can think of this as defining an
implicit function that says for any
Alpha and Delta what is the beta at
which I start using the Rooney rule
right at some level of bias I say now
the level bias is so high I need to
start using it and it can be a function
elephant build so we can think of that
beta is implicitly a function and okay
the actual functional forms of these
even for K equals two rather complicated
so I'm not really gonna talk about the
functional forms it was striking to us
that's so complicated because I've told
you the whole model there's not a lot
going on in the model and so the fact
this is the exact condition is a little
surprising but if you plot this implicit
function of beta I was talking about you
get this which in its own way is also
sort of complicated so let me sort of
walk you through this because embedded
in this is sort of two things as I said
that I felt like I learned about bias
from staring at this so again alpha goes
this way this is shrinking Alpha Delta
goes this way this is a string
so as we go this way there are fewer and
fewer X candidates and so it makes sense
that this thing is peeling upwards
because you need more and more bias to
be willing to use the Rooney rule right
if only 20% of your pool is X candidates
only 5% your pools XK nodes you would
need a lot of bias to be willing to use
it maybe no amount of bias would be
sufficient let's come back to that
question Delta is a little more
complicated right so as Delta goes to 0
I get more and more heavy tailed
distributions where the outliers get
more and more extreme that tends to have
the property that when somebody wins
they may be winning by a huge amount and
so you're very hesitant to swap them out
for somebody else and so this sort of
peels upward as Delta gets small so
although not completely because there's
this totally weird region which I won't
try to explain in this talk where it's
actually non monotone where as you vary
Delta you go from wanting from not
wanting to use the rule to wanting to
use it to not wanting to use it again
and so complicated things are happening
let's first talk about this cliff though
because it's actually climbing to
infinity and this cliff climbing to
infinity a sort of an interesting point
which says this is the frontier at which
you wouldn't even want to use the Rooney
rule in the case of infinite bias as you
mentioned this whole surface is 4 K goes
to so let me do this discussion for K
equals 2 where it's already messing them
ok so what does that frontier look like
right what are the values of alpha and
Delta for which the Rooney Rule does or
doesn't improve utility as the PI's
company in other words when she reserved
a slot for an Afghan in the case of
infinite bias now this sort of
interesting question so it says suppose
I'm giving out a prize to two people and
if I didn't constrain people's behavior
they would always just give it to the
top to Y candidates because somehow when
they go to give out Ward's Y candidates
are the only names that come to mind but
I could constrain their behavior and say
no this award will have one goes to an X
candidate one goes to a Y candidate I'm
imposing that now we'd like to look back
20 years later at the history of our
award look at everyone's Google Scholar
citation counts maybe add them up and
say in which world are we going to be
prouder of the people who we gave the
award to in the world where I was always
just giving it to 2y candidates or in
the row I gave it to one X and one Y
that's a concrete question where you go
and look at where in which one do I
increase the sum of expectation
the surprising fact which in the end has
a explanation that makes sense that no
matter how small the fraction of X
candidates there's a small enough
parallax bone so that you should use the
Rooney rule in other words even if only
5% of your pool is from group X there's
some small enough power lodgement
meeting a heavy enough tail on the
distribution that even though only 5%
congroo px you should still if I'm
trying to maximize utility reserve a
slots for someone from group X and the
other slots for the 95% from good boy
and and for a very concrete
performance-based reason because if you
look back later and look at how did
these random variables actually turn out
you will actually have done better by
reserving that slot so I can sort of
just sketch why that's true but then let
me talk about why that's why that's so
weird
this is fine yeah so this is this this
fly is all about K equals to infinite
bias which means you would never give it
on your own yet um actually I let me run
to the proof and let me talk about why
it's so weird so the argument is Z star
is the expected maximum of n draws from
power law of x1 plus Delta this is the
value of the top Y candidate because the
top Y candidate comes from n people I'm
drawing power law from each one and I'm
taking the best one because again my
ability to rank within each group is
perfect in this simple model the
problems I just can't merge them I'm
always putting why can't experience now
without the Rooney rule the other
candidate we pick will certainly be the
second why can't because we have
infinite bias and if you do a little
work with maximum power laws you get
that the expected value of that one is
Delta over 1 plus Delta x this is Easter
with the Rooney rule the other can it
will be the top x candidate that's now Z
star but scaled down by the fact there
only alpha n of them and so I get again
doing a little work with power laws it
turns out to be alpha to the 1 over 1
plus Delta times e star I just compare
these two I cancel the Z star and I get
it improves utility if alpha is greater
than Delta over 1 plus Delta that to the
1 plus Delta so therefore no matter how
small elf is there's a sufficiently
small Delta so alphas bigger than well
let me tell you why we wrote down this
thing and then we're like this can't be
right
because think about what we're saying we
have a hundred percent we have a hundred
applicants hundred percent say 20
percent are from group why we're
reserving a slot for them take group X
which has 80% of people split it in half
call them arbitrarily group a and Group
B each has 40% of the people now the
best person group a an expectation is
better than the best person group from
group X because their 40% of your day is
and only 20% good the best person from
Group B is better than the best person
group X and yet for some reason we're
saying retreat we're lumping together a
and B each of whom has someone better
than group X and we're treating crew
back separately how can that possibly be
improving utility right it seems wrong
right
you see the problem if I just chose to
think of group X as having these two
groups of 40 percent each so what's
going on so what's going on is that it's
not the case that we're comparing a the
best Danae and the best and X against
the best may in the best in B in both
cases we're picking the best of a union
B we're always getting the better of
those two the other one we pick from
from a union B is known to be the second
best and when you have a very very heavy
tailed power law whereas the person from
group X because of the infinite bias we
have no idea what the upper bound on
them is and so the point is when you
have a very heavy tailed power law the
value of not having some conditional
upper bound on their performance is
extremely powerful the fact that we know
that the second curve I can that we
picked is not the top person already
puts this big constraint on how high
they I mean they're probably very good
but there's some upper bound the person
group X there's no upper bound because
the bias meant we never actually
directly compared them to someone
genuinely okay so that was the first
thing I learned about bias that I really
hadn't kind of understood I have but it
really follows from very simple
assumptions and it's interesting it's
happening in this power law regime which
is exactly the realm of Google Scholar
counts view counts download statistics
where we often apply things like the
Rooney rule
let me tell you the second thing I
learned about
from this and that's the following so
well when we go to analyze this the
basic object that we need to understand
in this analysis is what you might call
an expectation conditional on comparison
okay so that's the following thing the
expectation of some random variable a
given that a is greater than C to
constant C times some other random
variable T think of a and B as sort of
the top this is kind of a stylized thing
abstracting from the analysis we're
doing I think of a and B as the top
cannas in the two groups C is some level
of bias it says we only you know when we
pick a it's because they have to be like
bigger than two times B and so we're
interested in how they are given that
they're bigger than two times the top
can the other groups right because
there's a bias to a factor of two right
so now we're back in the world of finite
bias where things are more complicated
and so syntactic it's very compact thing
to write down
we felt like we understood it going in
but it turns out this kind of
construction is a real mess okay this
idea that this person is better than
twice this other person both of whom
were drawn from some distribution so and
this actually showed up in the empirical
work for example in Cynthia du Bois as
work on there any role where a natural
question to ask is what was the win-loss
record of minority head coaches before
the Rooney rule and what was the
win-loss record afterwards and you
actually find again there are small
numbers and now there's really small
numbers be involved but that somehow
within some approximation the win-loss
record minority head coaches before the
rule was actually slightly higher
potential because they were passing
through a stronger filter because of the
bias afterwards they became more Mauri
Mauri equalized that's sort of intuitive
higher filters you mean they're doing
better but is that really what's going
on so let's say I have these independent
random variables a and B drawn from some
distribution and I'm going to find a
function of C I'm going to sweep over
the bias and ask what happens to this
expectation in other words how good is a
candidate experiencing bias when they
have to be twice as good as the
competition because of biased how good
you expect to be when they have to be
three times as good as the competition
because of bias how about ten times as
good right that's what happens as I
sweep across C so F of C is how could I
expect this can to be when they're
subjected to a level bias equal to a
factor of C what can we say about this
for example here's the most simple thing
you'd like to ask is it monotone
increasing and see if cants have to pass
through increasing levels of bias does
it follow that expectation they're
better okay
I could tell us actually as a say a
parable about hiring let's say I had to
research labs both research labs prefer
hiring applied people to theory people
so in the first research lab they're
going to every er their interview a
theory candidate and applied candidate
and the theory candidate has to be at
least twice as good as the applied
candidate to get hired the other layout
drawing from the same distribution
interview is a theory candidate and
applied candidate and but the fear can
have to be three times as good or more
compared to the applied can in order to
get hired now we're gonna look back
retrospectively 20 years later there
will be fewer Theory candidates at the
second lab will they be better on
average because that's a pass through
the higher filter that's that's the
montanus knee question the answer is not
necessarily
they may actually be for some
distributions that may actually be lower
and that's the sense in which I mean
this this quantity is a complete mess
that we don't really fully understand
here's a simple example to convince you
of this imagine this is the distribution
so it's just a four-point distribution
actually they're even simpler
distributions where this happens so
imagine every year this theory and
applied can are drawn from just region
where their quality to either 1 5 9 or
13 uniformly random so the sample space
is just this four by four grid there are
16 possible kinds of recruiting years
that you can have right this is the
quality of the theory Canada's quality
applied camp what is the event a greater
than to be look like it says in these
four kinds of years you end up hiring
the theory candidate right so when the
theory can it's 13 and the apply can
it's 5 that's greater than 2 times 5 so
you hire them similarly these 3 and so
your expected value is the average
quality over these which is 10 when you
have to be three times as good then the
slope shifts downward and you're only
averaging over these three points right
because you can only hire a theory
candidate in this world when the apply
can it was really really bad which
actually puts less of a constraint on
with you so here actually you do the
average against 9 so it says if I were
to go and look at the research labs 20
years later in this very stylized
scenario the research lab with the
higher filter actually has worse theory
Canada's on it
three people in every tree and in real
life we would look at this and we'd say
that could be for any number of reasons
which in real life would probably be the
dominant reasons for example a lab with
that high a filter is probably gonna be
unwelcoming to theoreticians who won't
want to go there and so that's why you
have weaker people there or if they
really have such a high filter they're
probably also bad at evaluating
theoreticians as they pick the wrong
people maybe that's true also
but neither of those has to be true this
could happen for purely arithmetic ariza
that's right and that's somehow the
point that this is a very messy concept
that we're dealing with right and
somehow this is at the heart of what we
have to do when we analyze the effect of
something like the rodeo we're looking
at these expectations conditional on
comparison okay even Bieber coming from
heavy-tailed distribution zone know so
actually for heavy tailed distributions
one thing we have to prove which this is
suggest someone on trevally yeah at
least for power law distributions if
they actually that function is monotone
we're just somehow the first step we
need you can certainly have a continuous
density function where it's not Manto
and i just put some bumps into it and
then i simulate something like this
actually we don't know it's a nice
question do all say you know modal just
density functions have the property that
this thing as much of increasing someone
may know the answer that we weren't able
to figure out expectations which means
you kind of suggest that you have to run
this process many many times to get the
predicted effect yeah the really kind of
bounds that say well how how many times
do you have to do this for the thanks to
show with high probabilities yeah that's
a interesting question because right
it's based on outliers now the outliers
are relatively frequent because it's
power law but yeah we have some some
some work on that sort of how fast this
is this is converging it's yeah I don't
think there's necessarily a crisp answer
cuz it's gonna depend on on the power
law exponent but the convergence here is
actually reasonably fast it's also
easily fast you know the other parameter
in which we might ask but convergence is
the number of applicants in because all
these are asymptotic statements in that
they are the convergence is relatively
quick in that the correction terms
we dealing with their things like sort
of 1 plus log n over N and so once n
gets to be in the hundredths we're
actually seeing this but yeah it's it W
into question the expectations also say
expectations of power laws are part of
the challenge here right when we're
we're looking at sort of average you
know what's the total revenue
now of course average is often what you
care about right if I'm hiring a team of
sales people I care about the total
revenue they generate I don't care about
some other thing but it's an issue
initially that we have to think about it
we could do a similar analysis saying
what is the probability that the Rooney
rule produces a positive change for
example rather than the expected change
and then we get a somewhat simpler
analysis but still has some of the
subtlety that we're seeing here yeah the
previous results were you were showing
what beta you needed given the other
parameters would you expect that if you
had a little bit of noise to the
estimation process it would be about the
same or does it change it dramatically
good question yeah so noise is a nice a
nice question thing about the results we
have right now say for sufficiently
small noise we get roughly the same
results as the noise gets larger it's
interesting question whether some
non-trivial sort of discrete transition
happens and in what's going on and
that's not something that we then we
fully understand in the infinite bias
case it's easy easy to understand in the
finite bias case yeah it isn't it's
clear you know the questions let me ask
a kind of timekeeping brushings wrap-up
and like yeah ok ok in that case let me
mention because you asked about max only
mentioned one more thing less
complicated than the reasoning about the
Rooney Rule which sort of goes even more
directly to Scott pages work on
diversity and then I'll wrap up so
fundamentally what we've been talking
about is we're about we're choosing a
shortlist of K people out of n people
and they've really been two things we've
been talking about one is how do we
evaluate individuals what score do we
give them and the other is this question
of how to evaluate the set and so far
the set we've just been summing we might
want to use some other function to
evaluate the set and what happens if we
have some other function right so the
point is if we're just evaluating by the
sum we should be doing what we've been
doing we should compute every
he's expected value and take the max
back to Billy but what if we're back in
this interviewing context where really
the reason we look to K people is to
pick the best one should we actually
right okay so imagine the following
setup I look at the applicants I have to
assign each one a numerical score I have
to rank them by their score but I'm
gonna be judged on the best person I
pick because maybe this is an interview
context maybe I'm a graduate admissions
committee that says what we really want
is for the most famous graduate from our
program to be as high as possible
maybe we're choosing a team and we want
you know we can be judged by the best
idea anyone the team has but for all
those reasons max is kind of a natural
thing to look at how do we do if we use
the expectation as a score is there some
other score we should be using so let me
show you one final example which I think
also sort of teaches us something about
the problem with the signing scores so
this is the sort of call contest
objective we're gonna bring in the case
shirt list we're gonna pick one after
the interview and we're scored by by the
max so using the mean to sort people has
the following worrisome behavior think
of K is large here suppose I just had a
pool I had two K applicants K of them
produced for high-risk high-reward they
produced value K minus one was probably
one over K and K of them are really safe
deterministic they produce value one was
probably one okay so a test that
evaluates the expectation chooses the
second group of candidates because they
have expectation one rather than one
minus a tiny bit but as you might not be
surprised to hear that would be a bad
choice I should really do is I certainly
do much better by picking the K
high-risk high-reward ones why because
each of them succeeds overwhelmingly in
this case with probably one over K so
the chance that least one of them
succeeds is a constant it's one minus
one minus one over K to the K which is
converging to one minus one over he so
with constant probability I reap the
enormous reward and so an expectation
and again we're looking expected value
I'm doing much better
so ranking by expected value is hurting
me a lot if I my goal is to maximize the
expected quality of the Max now Scott
page came across similar examples and
sort of ended up there and said this is
the problem
using scores right when you score people
and you rank them you know he uses this
as an indictment of SATs and GREs that's
reducing people to a unit dimensional
number and then when you sort and rank
you might actually miss the opportunity
to do really well so my throw
raghav and i looked at this and we're
intrigued by the following question is
the problem with scores or the problem
with expected value is the score all
right just because expected value isn't
working maybe there's some more clever
yoona dimensional score I could be using
that would actually let me do well and
the answer is that's actually what's
happening here's a better test that you
could use I'm trying to pick the max
rather than say let's look at the mean
performance of candidate I let's look at
a different quantity
let's take hand at I and again we're in
a stylized role we assume we know their
distribution let's imagine you drew K
times from that person's distribution
and you took the max so this is the best
they would do if they live their life K
times over independently alright this is
their upside potential let me as that as
the score it's again just a single
number so I throw away all the
information about the distribution I
just keep that one number that's now my
new GRE score my new SAT score and I
sort by that then the theorem you can
prove is that there's some absolute
constants that see so there's actually a
factor of C approximation to the optimum
all right if I could know everything
about the distribution and solve the
np-hard optimization problem of picking
the K that we're gonna have the highest
expected maximum I would not be better
than a factor of C times what I'm doing
by simply computing this metric and
sorting on it so there are a couple
things and this will be my final point
here a couple things that we learn from
this right one is that just because a
vanilla test isn't working like the
expected value doesn't mean that the
idea of unit dimensional test isn't
working sometimes you just need a more
subtle test the other said it was sort
of striking that you know we often think
about you know the importance of hiring
employees or admitting students based on
potential right we're not looking at
performance were looking at potential
the question is what might potential
mean this is sort of one argument that
it's saying let's not look at their mean
value let's look at their sort of top
one over K quantile value that's their
upside potential and notice that K is
scaled to the size of the team that
you're
all right so if I'm admitting ten people
I'm interested in the one-tenth quantile
if I'm eating a hundred people I might
be interested in again in the world by
me optimizing the max the max is a
particular thing you might want optimize
more generally there's a lot of
interesting questions here some of which
we've resolved some which are nice open
questions about given the way in which
you evaluate sets is there a single unit
dimensional test score you can apply and
the answer is sometimes yes sometimes no
you can construct situations where there
is no single number you can put on each
person's distribution that actually gets
you to within a constant factor value
all right so with that all right I'll
wrap up as I said this has been in part
a definitional activity right going into
a lot of the literature on fairness on
diversity and selection on bias
selection and to think about some of the
basic rules that people are using trying
to build models around them so we can
get some insights into what's going on
in a lot of these cases I think what
we're finding is you can get quite
complex behaviors from relatively simple
in the empty interventions right things
like the Rooney rule things like
selecting people so as to achieve the
max you can write down very simple
specifications that induce very very
complicated behaviors and I think all of
these lead to interesting open questions
when we embed this in some kind of
larger context right in the end the
reason we introduced you know an
intervention like risk scores the reason
we introduced an intervention like the
Rooney rule is because we're thinking
about the dynamics of time going forward
we're think about what the world is
going to look like five years from now
or ten years from now if we implement
this rule and of course dynamics over
time we're going to introduce their own
set of complex behaviors they're gonna
change the mix of people that we see in
the training and test sets that we work
with they're actually even as the
economists tell us change people's
decisions about effort because if you're
being evaluated in a biased world and
there's bias against you there's
essentially a tax on your effort for
every unit of effort you put in you're
only getting back one minus Epsilon
reward because some of that effort is
actually being lost to the bias against
you and in that kind of a world people
where this bias against we're going to
actually make different decisions about
effort right they're actually going to
rationally potentially invest less
effort thereby you know sort of
in a unfortunate way reinforcing the
bias right because of the bias they
invest less effort and that's somehow
confirms what people believed in the
bias and you get into this very
dangerous positive feedback loop the
point being some of these interventions
can help break that feedback loop right
if we force people to look beyond the
bias they have that actually changes the
incentive calculation the people in the
by it in the bias group might make about
investing effort and actually break out
of that so I think there's some various
ting questions about the dangers over
time both on the data that we see in the
incentives and that's gonna I think lead
to a lot of interesting work going
forward thanks very much so that's be
given the the challenges with valuating
folks and sensitivity analysis applied
to this yeah you get a sense for various
kinds of variants over what you know
really slamming the results and doing a
job in terms of yeah so I think there's
a question you might go oh yeah yeah
some right so the question is given the
difficulties in forming accurate
evaluations of people what happens when
there's variance and the estimates yeah
I guess I would say two things which is
notion of appearance is operating at two
to two levels first of all all of these
cases we're talking about people where
what I see about them is a distribution
and their true performance can be drawn
by diffusion so in some sense the models
all build variants in and I think that's
telling us is that the heavier the tail
in the power law the more uncertainty I
have about how large the outlier is
going to be so in a way these all sort
of almost start from the difficulty in
forming it right all of these questions
what would be different if I had a
deterministic evaluation of each person
everyone's mean dramatise region but
then there's error in the parameters
yeah errors in the parameters now is
sort of the second level of this yeah so
I think again in in some of these cases
I think what's happening is it gets much
much more challenging when there's large
variance so most of the results that we
have basically say for sufficiently
small errors we get roughly something
that sort of changes continuously and
what I've been talking about here but
interesting questions sort of what's the
threshold like how much error can we
tolerate before qualitatively different
behaviors start happening yeah and a lot
of it's largely an open question okay
would it be practical in some cases to
measure data from from a group and then
then adjust your selection algorithms
instead of trying to fix them yeah
that's a nice question can we measure
beta and then maybe use that it so
there's sort of two questions there one
is it possible we might be able to
measure some notion of beta there
potentially and we've thought a little
about this and have a couple because to
the extent that alpha and Delta are sort
of known the sort of one missing thing
and and the selection rate is know sort
of one missing thing there is is is beta
and in some sense some of the behavioral
work has started to get into trying to
estimate that that quantity mainly
through lab experiments although we
could do it with historical data now the
question could we use that as an
intervention we could say what you
should do is just adjust your estimates
my beta that will correct for the device
I think the challenge there is one very
important thing about the Rooney Rule
and actually everything in the analysis
that we did is that it never requires
people to write down a number and
manipulate the number all it ever does
is ask people to make ordinal
comparisons between things and what
that's consistent with is the fact that
in in the sort of field work on this and
also some of the lab work it's very much
like you would like to say you know say
we really cared about Google Scholar
count just as a pedagogical feature we
don't necessarily really have that be
our one mental feature it's very to get
people to say I'm gonna look at a
candidate yes a future Google Scholar
count twelve thousand this one future
goals all account fourteen thousand okay
that person wins but I'm gonna divide
down by 1.2 because of bias even before
I ever got to the factor 1.2 the idea
you're gonna write down estimates that
seems very very hard for people to do
and so what people are doing is that so
this is sort of a model which there's an
abstraction barrier there are numbers
operating below the surface but all the
people are doing is being ordinal
comparisons and the interventions
operating there but I think it's very
instantly mapping couldn't get the
intervention where you address the
trebles oh you helping sure the
shortlist B yeah so you could have an
intervention says you must continue
interviewing people until you get to
say a Canada from group X that would be
a sort of no minute
I mean fixed K we pick up kit with a
priority distribution yes the data I
want to see like it says variation in K
and then again that would be helpful in
estimating beta again I'm not sure that
would help with people trying to form
their own numerical estimates I I did I
do think it's somehow key in these
models that the agents being modeled to
make an ordinal comparisons not not
numerical valuations but yeah if there
were natural variation in in K it's also
the case that the rule is introduced so
far says one out of K but you know
there's presumably some actual parameter
like L out of K right you can mention an
L order Rooney rule that says you must
have L of your case Lots be reserved for
a group and it's certainly not clear
that in fact obviously it's not the case
that one is always the optimal number
our comparison here has been about one
versus zero but you know one versus two
versus three is better if I'm gonna
interview K people for a job that I'm
gonna give one person a job and you'll
lead at RIT a little bit in your graph
of a number of coaches and you said oh
maybe recently we've just decided that
the basically the decision is made in
advance and I go through the motions of
interviewing K people which include at
least one underrepresented person um
have you done any any thinking about
like is there something more we learn
presumably we do the interviewing in a
reasonable world to learn something more
about the candidates in order to make a
better informed decisions yeah have you
done any any analysis on like hidden
information and how that might yeah this
model of who that actually gets a job
yeah so I think that's that searching
question as you can see and we like in
discussion of the max at the end the way
the way we're modeling there is there's
a random variable some distribution the
act of interviewing now materializes a
value from it which is a very extreme
form of you know
the distri should represent certainty
now I have a deterministic value you
could imagine sort of things and some of
this shows up in some of the theoretical
economics work on discrimination in
labor market which deals with very
different models that we're talking
about where for example there's a
temporary labor market in a permanent
labor market so some nice work that a
well
yield yielding chanted at a harbor just
like that recently where the temporary
labor market gives me better information
about the candidate but still not
perfect and then that allows me to make
decisions about the permanent labor
market that allows us to model things
such as I have in three months in
internship program which I learned some
you know information about the candidate
but it's not that I now know everything
right and so so this is interesting sort
of staging effect where I could invest
different amounts of effort right I
could interview someone for one day or
two days I could give them an internship
for two months or three months I could
do a variety of things that are going to
come at different costs and you know
increase the amount of information I
have about this person or reduce the
uncertainty of those person and so I
think some of some of the work in that
domain may be it may also provide some
insight into what this how's my work at
the end you mentioned this idea of the
mats and sort of bringing back to where
you were earlier and definitions of
fairness with calibration is expected
value right and you could transform that
from instead of being one zero
recidivism it's actually estimation of
harm right and take a mats over a group
where you start matching based on
features that's true we start thinking
in this rink based world and in
defaulting on loans right it can be
actually again and I'm about a variable
of them out loss yeah how do we start
thinking of fairness in this world of
you know ranking based on that yeah
that's that's interesting question we're
we're we're doing some kind of ordinal
ranking um yeah so we've we looked a
little a little bit at this because
ranking is actually a nice intervention
when I'm trying to say take an existing
policy based on a human estimate of risk
and then using some kind of algorithmic
intervention and so one thing we've
looked at in the empirical work that
we've been doing on judges and bail is
is to say let's let's imagine a judge
that releases some number of people we'd
like to use the risk tool to sort them
by predicted risk and basically detain
the ones who are viewed as the most
risky right and so you can imagine some
interaction between the human
decision-maker and the algorithm based
on ranking where the human picks a set
the algorithm ranks them and they're
sort of knocks the most most risky few
out of it so in that domain we might
then think about the balance between
different groups right whether there's
there's there's this bias going on these
different groups we might say for
example of this set that you knock out
we need to keep some kind of approximate
composition but between the groups which
we a kind of Rooney rule like activity
applied to the algorithms decision to
sort of knock people off the top end of
the max ranking but I think there's a
lot of things you could potentially do
right because there's now this
interaction of the human decision makers
selection the algorithms sorting and
some notion of fairness as implied by
the composition so I think there are a
lot a lot of engine questions there that
one could potentially try modeling the
expectation of the max is an interesting
thing and it just reminds me of with SCT
you can take it multiple times and then
you just report the mass which sounds
like kind of weird ahead of time but
given what you've found it's actually
maybe a more correct thing to do than
just a lot of people to take it once to
get kind of just an expected average
value yeah they're similar like when we
interview you know 10 people interview
the candidate perhaps we should do 10
really really tough interviews and take
the max the max response if one person
like them we keep them instead of kind
of averaging yeah I think we're
seasoning on the average or the total or
the sum or whatever that the max is kind
of a different world yeah yeah now I
should say it's gonna depend on what is
right you know this is in a world where
you're optimizing for the max max
performance so you know I think if you
were yeah if you were gonna be hiring
for a commune of deep thinkers who are
gonna sit in their rooms and have Grady
and then out was gonna come the best
idea of all of them then yeah if if if
you qualitatively if you have a
candidate who really was somebody wanted
Direction you're like that's what we're
trying to select for we're trying to
select for there being some because when
I pick K people and I just got to pick
the max I'm gonna get the top one over K
quantile somebody right that's
intuitively what's happening right I
think and if you're picking say for a
research lab where everybody is
producing output and we're telling
something much more like an LP norm
closer to l1 or l2 then I may not be
optimizing for the max selection being
based on a max like saige
scores or something is that one yeah
correct first I wouldn't I think and you
can sort of even argue other aspects of
college applications right so you know
candidates often try many different say
extracurricular activities and if they
you know they might try six or eight of
them if they really succeed at one
that's what they write about in their
application essay and so implicitly the
system is set up for them to select the
max of all the activities that they try
to maybe that makes sense you can even
think of this in completely different
domains right if you're on vacation for
five days and some you know new place
and you're gonna eat five dinners at
five restaurants and you're sort of
hedonic experience the whole thing is
gonna be the best of the five dinners
that you had it says you should actually
evaluate Yelp reviews differently right
you should be looking at upside because
in the end remember the best of those
five not the median so last question
though wrap up yeah so on the first
brother talk you talked about this group
calibration as one of the alternatives
so if you were to drop that what would
you want to replace it with well so in a
way I want to keep the other two right
so I had three things that were moved to
and then drop the drop calibration what
are you replacing with well I guess I
would I should check to make sure I
understand the question but I have three
things right now calibration balance for
positive balance for negative they're
mutually incompatible in some sense I
have to drop one so you know one of the
arguments and this work of hard price
and shred bro makes this argument if we
drop calibration then we're actually
just right
we don't have put anything back in
because we're now just barely gonna
satisfy that right so we're gonna
equalize the positives equalize the
negatives and we now have lost all our
degrees of freedom to do anything else
and now we're going to try optimizing
accuracy within if I really were to put
her condition back in I might get to
some new impossibility result which I
which I couldn't handle so the argument
that they they that they make in their
work is you know let's think about
situations where calibration is not the
important thing what's important is that
people who have similar behaviors should
be given similar scores and that that's
really what fairness is and that's a
compelling argument and in some domains
and so equalizing pause does equalizing
negatives I've now sort of exhausted my
degrees of freedom and the constraints
in some sense yeah
okay well thanks very much
[Applause]